you have warts because your feet are
dirty no
no no no bunions are caused by wearing
heels
leave your stilettos out of this the
stilettos did not cause your bunion
cutting the sides of my toenail will
prevent
an ingrown toenail no
absolutely not i am dr sarah holler i am
a foot and ankle surgeon
and i practice in new york new jersey i
got into foot and ankle because i wanted
to be a ballerina i wanted
so badly but i was not that good so i
ended up being a doctor instead
and my feet definitely thanked me and
i'm dr brad shafer
i'm a doctor of podiatric medicine we
treat everything
below the knee and today we will be
debunking
all the myths about feet pedicures
gave me toenail fungus i think yes and
no i mean
you can get fungus from anywhere you can
be in a carpet so i can't prove that
it's
not gonna happen here but i can't prove
that it will either i definitely
take precaution when i go to a pedicure
salon i bring my own nail polish and if
this is part of your self-care ritual
don't stop going but at the same time
just be cautious that's all
you can get toenail fungus from anywhere
pedicures are safe if they're done in a
safe sterile
environment they do clean their
instrumentation they have these sanitary
bags that go inside of the the bathtub
soaks that should be changed out between
every person that comes through
so they do take precaution but at the
same time again anywhere there's a
a warm hot moist environment
it's like a breeding ground for fungus
cutting the sides of my toenail
will prevent an ingrown toenail
no absolutely not when you cut your nail
you're supposed to cut it
straight across so when you do that
the nail doesn't grow in to the corner
creating
an ingrown which can create infection
and a lot of pain
so what everyone thinks sometimes is
that they got the actual nail around it
it'll grow out around it
that's not true because the actual nail
matrix where the nail grows from
from behind the actual skin it actually
grows as
a square you only see the rounded part
so
by actually cutting it how you want it
to grow it's not going to change the
actual root of it and how it's
meant to grow right i couldn't agree
more what's going to cause
ingrown toenails is your toenail
so when that gets cut too short it grows
right into the corner of your skin
it's like a little pin once that starts
penetrating the skin it creates an
infection
pus swelling redness not a good look
it hurts so just cut them straight
across you'll be in the clear
this is one i know i get all the time
oh gosh all right you have warts
because your feet are dirty no no
no no you do not get warts because your
feet
are dirty warts are a virus you get
viruses from all kinds of things
viruses can hide anywhere and they just
lay on
surfaces they can be on yoga mats any
kind of exercise equipment
pools gyms showers they're everywhere
but don't be afraid
live your life just make sure you wear
those shower shoes
wipe down your mats if you're doing yoga
or in a gym
and you know don't overly share your
stuff if you look at your feet there are
small cracks between
each of these skin layers and you don't
even feel them they're not bleeding
they're not
cuts they're just microscopic tears in
your skin and that's how the viruses get
in
when you do get a wart you know which
ultimately is caused by a virus
that little wart can spread into a
huge wart cluster that's why you want to
get checked out to make sure that that
little thing
can be treated real quick when you come
to our office we do
an acid treatment and what the acid does
is it
really just eats down at the wart so it
exfoliates out the good skin and kills
the virus
sometimes there's a surgery that's
needed and you actually
pair out the wart but if you get it
checked early enough
you don't have to do that and you can
get it treated in one treatment
i actually love this one so it's only
athletes
get athlete's feet that is a
straight no so athlete's feet is
actually
a fungus and it's called tinnie of pedis
right
so when you have a fungus like that
usually it comes from
warm moist environments a lot of times
in our socks and shoes when we sweat
it's kind of like harboring like a
little petri dish in there
once all that gets in there it festers
and it can create
a very good looking environment for
fungus bacteria
all types of not good things that's why
you're always told to change out your
socks when they start getting sweated
if you're just working and walking
around every day your feet can still
sweat
too not just athletes have those warm
moist environments
everybody does so change out your socks
change out your shoes
use some powder from time to time
that'll help too bunions
are caused by wearing heels no
absolutely not leave your stilettos out
of this the stilettos did not cause your
bunion
mom dad grandma grandpa somebody in your
family your family tree
passed it down to you baby you were born
this way
a bunion and actually it's not a bump
growing off the side of your foot which
everyone seems to think it's actually a
deformity being the bone behind your big
toe is actually shifting
from this straight up and down position
and tilting sideways it's like the
leaning tower of pisa right
it's not the actual stiletto that's the
problem it may be
worsened by wearing the stiletto where
it pushes on the bunion and makes
it bigger but it's not actually caused
by the actual shoe you're wearing so
what i tell patients that have bunions
that they want to wear
a cute stiletto maybe go a little bit
lower so i recommend something where
your actual
bunion can maybe come out the side of it
you can definitely support
and help bunions right but they're not
just going to go
away they will develop throughout time
and unfortunately
sometimes get worse you know as we age
there's no way to get rid of a bunion
without surgery
those things out there called yoga toes
or like toe spacers
are out there to help us but when you
remove them
not doing much good are they they're
kind of like eyeglasses they only work
when you wear them
very true my feet are fine because i
trained them to walk in stilettos i
think
yes and no i mean i don't think they're
good for you but i definitely think you
can train your feet because you can get
used to them so when you're wearing
these things your heel is going here and
it attaches to your achilles and that's
what actually shortens as you
persistently wear these over time
your achilles gets shorter and shorter
which actually causes a ton of issues
with the front of your foot
that inserts down here this is where the
ball of your foot is and that's where
all of the pressure goes
to five little bones in the base of your
foot so i do think
you can kind of train your feet to walk
in stilettos but in no way shape or form
is it good
healthy or give you longevity like a
valet shoe
you know you're gonna park you're gonna
get out somewhere you're gonna walk for
maybe two steps and sit down
that's a great shoe but other than that
not a long-term shoe
you can't do anything for a broken toe
myth we get this question all the time
oh my gosh and it's frustrating when you
have a broken toe that's a bone
you broke a bone in your foot right
there's definitely stuff you can do
for the broken toes with a toe it may
not just be a simple fracture where the
actual bone is cracked you can actually
dislocate it which basically means not
only is the bone crack but the ligaments
are actually
loosened up so it pops over to the side
you need to get it popped back into
place and then it needs to really
structurally be
supported by the other topos item
otherwise it can re-dislocate
and cause major issues down the line so
it's really important that you get your
toes checked out if you think you may
have fractured or even bumped it wrong
you see black and blue
you need to go in and have it buddy
taped basically when the toes can get
taped together your doctor will teach
you how to do it so you can safely heal
it takes four to six weeks for a bone to
heal so
you better just get in there faster then
i just start healing in a natural
process so it doesn't have to be
reset again it's normal for your feet to
hurt from standing all day
it is not normal my feet kind of bark at
the end of the day
especially when i'm in surgery for a
long time but ultimately
you know we have you know tips and tools
where your feet
should not hurt at the end of the day
supportive shoes compression socks
inserts all of these things can help
prevent
fatigue you know we have to support our
arches i mean they are critical for the
stability of our feet you have
26 bones and over a hundred ligaments in
the foot there's a lot that can go wrong
with our feet
appropriate shoe gear is the key none of
these like
flimsy shoes in the office anything with
a good sole and especially with a little
bit of a higher heel like so you have
like the nice support under your
achilles
i think really makes a big difference
especially if you're standing or walking
all day
all inserts are the same you've got this
a lot
absolutely no my foot is way different
than dr brad's foot we wouldn't need the
same insert
and i'm sure your foot is different and
everybody has something else going on so
just getting
you know an over-the-counter insert for
some people is okay but sometimes you
need a custom one
right i mean i couldn't agree more so if
you look at my shoes
i just wear an over-the-counter insole
these insoles have
nice arch support these are game
changers
and other people they have bigger
problems so they need
custom inserts and those are called
orthotics
and those are absolutely amazing too so
it really just depends
if you have victoria arthritis if you
have arthritis in your midfoot it helps
a lot of arthritic conditions which you
may think
is an old person thing young people can
get arthritis too
so orthotic can help anybody young too
old if you have really flat feet as a
kid
those are really important to help
stabilize the the growth plates as the
kid is growing
sprained ankles are no big deal false
thank you yes i agree dude we get this a
lot in our practice
when you sprain your ankle there are so
many things
that can go wrong so there are three
ligaments on the outside
of your ankle and when you roll it they
basically
blow out so what you have to do is you
have to stabilize that ankle
so the ligaments hold in a natural
position other than that
it'll just grow back floppy and scarred
down so
that's not going to be good for anyone
you're not going to be able to play the
sport that you love
so whenever you roll your ankle you have
to stabilize it so it heals normal
yes when it sprains you also run the
risk of the bones hitting into each
other so then that can cause
cartilage damage cartilage damage is a
really big
thing because it happens and then you
don't follow up
you're prone to early onset arthritis
and arthritis
is in no way good if i can walk after an
injury i don't need to see a doctor
false absolutely false just
no no no this is
not true so i had a patient come in last
week
he fell off a porch while he was hanging
out with friends
but he broke his ankle and had no idea
he walked on it for two weeks when i
showed him the x-ray he was
flabbergasted he walked around for you
know a week and a half without even
knowing that he broke it
there's also a lot of patients that we
see that don't necessarily
feel their feet like diabetics out there
sometimes you get stuff called
neuropathy and that can be tingling
numbing
burning sensation in your feet and you
just don't feel those
injuries so it's important to just get
it checked out
by dr sarah or i and we'll tell you if
there's any cause for concern
we debunked a lot of myths here we went
through a lot but definitely change your
shoes regularly make sure that you
you know don't share shoes with each
other trim your toenails appropriately
and go and get things checked out don't
wait until the last minute because it
could be broken even if you're still
walking on it
let's check my feet yeah i mean okay get
flexible
what yeah i mean it's kind of that's
pretty close
it's more impressive than i thought oh
my gosh it hurt my hip
come on you need
bug in these myths